[Music]
in 1982 a young nurse was suffering from
severe unrelenting depression she
couldn't work socialize or even
concentrate well enough to read the
newspaper one treatment changed
everything after two courses of
electroconvulsive therapy or ECT her
symptoms lifted she went back to work
then on to graduate school as she earned
high grades at first she talked openly
about her life-changing treatment but as
she realized many people had an
extremely negative impression of ect she
stopped sharing her experience ECT
carried a deep stigma leftover from a
history that bears little resemblance to
the modern procedure the therapy was
first used in medicine in 1938 in its
early years doctors administered a
strong electrical current to the brain
causing a whole body seizure during
which patients might bite their tongues
or even break bones modern ECT is very
different while a patient is under
general anaesthesia electrodes deliver a
series of mild electrical pulses to the
brain this causes huge numbers of
neurons to fire in unison a brief
controlled seizure a muscle relaxant
keeps spasms from spreading to the rest
of the body the only physical indication
of the electricity flooding the brain is
a twitching foot the treatment lasts for
about a minute and most patients are
able to resume normal activities about
an hour after each session ect is
commonly used to treat severe cases of
major depression or bipolar disorder in
patients who haven't responded to other
therapies or who have had adverse
reactions to medication half or more of
those who undergo treatment experience
an improvement in their symptoms most
patients treated with ECT have two or
three sessions per week for several
weeks some begin to notice an
improvement in their symptoms after just
one session while others take longer to
respond patients often continue less
frequent
treatments for several months to a year
and some need occasional maintenance
sessions for the rest of their lives
modern ECT is much safer than it used to
be but patients can still experience
side effects they may feel achy fatigued
or nauseated right after treatment some
have trouble remembering what happened
right before a session for example what
they had for dinner the previous evening
rarely they might have trouble
remembering up to weeks and months
before for most patients
this memory loss does improve over time
what's fascinating is the despite its
proven track record we still don't know
exactly why ECT works neurons in the
brain communicate via electrical signals
which influence our brain chemistry
contributing to mood and behavior the
flood of electrical activity sparked by
ECT alters that chemistry for example
ECT triggers the release of certain
neurotransmitters molecules that help
carry signals between neurons and
influence mental health ECT also
stimulates the flow of hormones that may
help reduce symptoms of depression
interestingly ECT maintenance works
better when paired with medication even
in patients who were resistant to
medication before as we come to a better
understanding of the brain
we'll likely be able to make ECT even
more effective in 1995 more than a
decade after her first course of ECT the
nurse decided to publish an account of
her experience because of the stigma
surrounding the treatment she worried
that doing so might negatively impact
her personal and professional life but
she knew ECT could make a difference for
patients when all else failed though
misperceptions about ECT persist
accounts like hers have helped make
doctors and patients alike aware of the
treatments life-changing potential
[Music]